most Kenyans use public transport to get
around that's why some bus service
providers are taking no chances this is
one of the busiest bus stations in a row
this city center we've got everyone and
these are the misses we've adopted along
said asking our conductors to make sure
vehicles are ventilated but is happening
the bath doors and windows on Sunday the
government put in place new restrictions
after two more cases of coronavirus were
confirmed bringing the total to three
president Uhuru Kenyatta addressed the
nation announcing the indefinite closure
of schools and universities along with a
bearing of all visitors from coronavirus
affected nations and asking Kenyans to
avoid using cash among other measures
government offices businesses and
companies are encouraged to allow
employees to work from home many Kenyans
in the city rely on casual labor for
their daily income and do not have
adequate medical insurance they woke up
to these headlines and are afraid things
could get worse people up bracing
themselves for potential total lockdown
if the disease continues to spread
government officials say you're not
there yet but some Kenyans we spoke to
here are concerned about how they'll
feed their families if they are told to
stay home
doubt on macho Cassell's treats to
passengers and says he cannot afford to
stay home even for one day
LM on anima Bhima if they have to stay
at all C for 30 days
what would we eat we sleep hungry my
family needs to be fed the landlord
needs to be paid health officials are
telling Kenyans not to panic
maintain good hygiene and follow the
guidelines being given they say the
government isolation facilities are
working and the country's prepared for
the worst this noise is at one of the
government hospitals are however
skeptical they say they don't have
proper protective gear and a me way of
ensuring their own families stay safe
theirs is just one of the many problems
that government faces as it tries to
prevent its small outbreak from getting
out of control
Catherine saw al-jazeera Nairobi Kenya